une question je vous en parle parce que
c'est là je je n'en peux plus vraiment
là la question qui revient
systématiquement et c'est là où le
journaliste a l'impression qui fait une
interview de qualité est ce que vous
êtes pour la dépénalisation du cannabis
je dois parler uniquement dans mon
dernier spectacle 30 secondes de la
dépénalisation du cannabis
sans prononcer d'ailleurs pour au contre
mais je crois que du fait de ma tête on
se dit métisse avec des cheveux il faut
vraiment revenir sur ce thème de la
dépénalisation du cannabis donc je pense
qu'il ya un grand délit de faciès dans
cette question qui m'amuse beaucoup et
je pense que tous les métis avec des
cheveux sont confrontés à cette question
même si leur carrière ou le rhum n'a
strictement rien à voir
je pense que même jo wilfried tsonga on
lui dit si vous avez fait un bon match
et vous êtes pour la dépénalisation du
cannabis donc est-ce qu'on peut à un
moment et arrêter de me poser cette
question sur la dépénalisation du
cannabis le blackface vous choque de
toute façon toutes les tout ce qui se
passe qui concerne les noirs en ce
moment et c'est là où ça devient très
intéressant c'est que dans cette société
qui se communautarise de plus en plus on
a l'impression que il ya des sujets qui
te concerne toi évidemment dès que c'est
un truc qui touche les noirs on
m'appelle un peu il faut quelqu'un de la
communauté entre guillemets je n'aime
pas ce terme je vais mettre entre
guillemets pour répondre donc que ce
soit le blackface que ce soit ça tout si
zemmour la plante journalistes qui
m'appelait oui qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous qu'être censée répondre à
cette question
alors moi maintenant je le redis
d'appeler un intellectuel noir dans le
spectacle j'ai cette boutade ouzou mais
il y en aura n'étaient pas disponibles
donc comment on fait
peut-on rire de tout là je crois que
tous les les collègues sont touchés par
ce fléau c'est vraiment là la création
qui revient systématiquement et c'est là
où le journaliste a l'impression qui
fait l'interview de qualité de cette
question le journal il se dit [ __ ] là
mon interview il passe un cap on est en
philo et quelque chose vraiment très
très profond dans mon interview que moi
et moi j'ai un classique pas tant je
réagirais prend chaque fois ça j
écoutais soit henry de tous on rit de
rien c'est inintéressant au possible
mais comme la question l'êtes aussi je
crois que maintenant voilà jeu
j'ai ma petite parade vous en prenez au
vegan dans votre spectacle
qu'est ce que vous avez contre c'est une
question qui m'amuse beaucoup parce que
ça montre ce qu'est devenu l'humour
aujourd'hui et on a l'impression que
faire de l'humour sur un thème ou une
communauté c'est être contre l or c'est
juste voilà il se trouve qu'il ya
énormément de débat on a vu dix mille
dans toutes les émissions télé de tokyo
et c'est sur l'aîné gagnent c'est un
thème
voilà très à la mode un frais thèmes de
société aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je
le traite c'est aussi parce que j'ai une
petite nièce qui et vegan je lui ai
précisé avant le spectacle un jour
j'étais en train de faire des heureux
chez moi habitent à pons de manger des
foetus est vinifié pas des foetus et des
em dit c'est pareil
et puis non je pense pas qu'un médecin
quand ils font des avortements il attend
que son jus d'orange et ses mouillettes
ça fait marrer chez moi j'en ai fait
tout tout un sketch mais pour autant je
n'ai rien contre les vegan en soit c'est
juste un thème de société dont tout le
monde parle en ce moment donc je
trouvais ça intéressant d'en parler dans
le spectacle mais ça montre évidemment
ce qui est devenu l'humour aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a l'impression que quand on
est comique qu'on doit parler pour
certains contre certains il était
comment emmanuel macron à l'école j'ai
été et c'est une réalité dans la même
école à savoir la providence à amiens
avec que le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron donc là je reprécise et j'y
réponds parce que c'est devenu une
obsession de tous les journalistes
j'ai été en contact direct avec emmanuel
macron on peut avoir du petit gossip
croustillants sur le président ado est
ce qu'ils avaient de la cne à quel âge
j'ai couché avec les premières filles
etc
je ne sais rien de tout ça je n'étais
pas un proche de manuel macron on a
effectivement des petites connaissances
en commun
moi j'avais un an de retard il avait un
an d'avancé donc même si on a le même
âge ça fait deux classes d'écart c'était
un brillant élève gt1 un élève très
médiocre qui a fini par se faire virer
au bout de je crois six mois de la
providence
donc ma scolarité tu as raté complet la
selle est une grande réussite je crois
que c'est ensuite il est parti henri iv
et cetera puis l'affairé
les grandes études comme on dit donc je
n'ai eu aucun contact direct avec le
président de la république il n'y aura
pas de détails croustillants sur son
adolescence
voilà comment il est et je ne sais pas
ce que vous auriez pu être rappeur je
vous en parle parce que c'est là je je
n'en peux plus mais alors on peut
souvent oui vous avez appartenu à un
groupe de rap qui s'appelle club spief
ton pendant votre votre jeunesse
est ce que vous auriez pu être rappeur
effectivement j'étais rappeur dans ce
groupe avec mes amis d'enfance et j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec cette question
parce que j'aime le rap et ce moment on
voit rap et c'est une vraie insulte à la
chose
c'est un moment très délicat en termes
de rythmiques j'ai jamais eu le sens du
rythme je pense que si boubacar is
entendez m'entends dérapé il y aurait de
réconciliation il ré c'est quoi ce
connard la paroisse de faire ça c'est
une honte
mais voilà si vraiment les journalistes
c'est solennelle vraiment ce que je dis
là vous pouvez arrêter de parler de ce
ce moment très gênant j'aurais été un
bon rappeur je vous aurais dit génial
mais là on est on est on est à un moment
vraiment c'est très pénible c'est très
pénible
il ya jamais rien lu je ne sais pas on
rêver de ça moi vous savez j'ai géré un
papa qui est médecin
j'aime à manquer prof j'ai grandi à
nogent sur marne le bois de vincennes
petite banlieue tranquille bourgeoise et
c est ce qui me faisait vibrer moi
c'était le ghetto de los angeles c'était
une double ou et/ou pack easy donc je me
suis dit je voulais cette attitude mais
bon voilà je suis restée toute ma vie à
un fils de médecin et de prof d'histoire
géo et je suis plus doués pour écrire
que pour le gangsta rap